[Музика]
Привіт усім, настав час для уроків англійської,
мене звуть de fauna, і у нас
ще один урок про подорожі, давайте йти
, це те місце, куди ми збираємося
сьогодні вирушити, подивіться на зображення
назад  щоб піти Нія, що ти знаєш про
це місце, ми на земній кулі, чи зможемо ми
знайти його, що ваше завдання для прослуховування,
дивіться і ловіть і будьте готові
завершити фразу Патагонія — це країна дзвонів,
давайте слухати далеко на легендарному краю
світу природні чудеса Патагонії чекають
цього останнього кордону Південної Америки,
схилу від Анд до
Антарктиди, що охоплює
малозаселені південні райони
Чилі та Аргентини,
жодне місце не захоплює уяву,
як Патагонія, це країна
легендарного вигляду,
де біжить мати-природа  шоу
готуйтеся відчути себе карликом перед могутніми
вулканами, що підносяться льодовиками та плаваючими
айсбергами, які неодмінно перетнуть ваш
шлях, готові завершити фразу, добрий
сер, Патагонія – це земля l  незвичайна
краса саме так, де вона розташована,
в якій частині світу, давайте знайдемо її
на земній кулі,
це Південна Америка, безперечно, які
країни поділяють її територію, Чилі та
Аргентина, малюк і який океан
поблизу
, тобто Атлантика,
звучить як урок географії  правий
хлопець, скажи, що це місце Патагонії,
країна легендарної краси, зараз
давайте подумаємо і відповімо на ці запитання, відповімо на
запитання номер один, що, на вашу
думку, можуть побачити і зробити туристи, які відвідують Патагонію,
що там робити для
туристів і що робити під номером два  які
тварини живуть у Патагонії,
зробіть свої прогнози, і давайте виконаємо це
завдання, тепер ви можете побачити зображення
та фрази в середині 20 секунд,
позначте зображення цими фразами,
щоб перше зображення у верхньому лівому
куті  прогулянка на човні,
безперечно, ще один вид діяльності, це
катання на гірських велосипедах, потрапити у верхній правий кут
, тобто спостерігати за пінгвінами, а
потім гуляти по лугах.
це Glazer
High King, тому що це льодовик
льодовик, тож давайте скажемо це разом
льодовик ваша черга
Glazer KITT не робіть це англійською
Glazer це, що британською англійською
американською англійською ви можете почути льодовик,
тому британською англійською glacier
повторюється  після того, як я украсю твої ворота
американською англійською, це ще
раз льодовик, ворота льодовика так низько, тиждень
англійською lazier хороша робота і
активність льодовик я прийшов добре,
давайте рухаємося далі, що відвідує
традиційне ранчо, у нижньому лівому
кутку це  стеження, а останнє
– верхова їзда, тож приділіть пару
секунд і перевірте, чи пам’ятаєте ви
всі ці фрази, назвіть малюнки
у довільному порядку.
Ісус
добре попрацював, за винятком часу для прослуховування,
подивіться на Туска, послухайте Джейн,
яка тільки що  повернись із яри для відстеження
в Патагонії та перевір свої прогнози,
твої прогнози щодо цих питань,
готовий перевірити, послухай та
занотуй, я щойно повернувся з походу  так, у Південній Америці це був мій
перший похід, я вважаю, що найкраще це можна
описати як прогулянку для насолоди
під час мого перебування в Південній Америці я пішов
на патагонську сходинку, це величезне
майже порожнє місце, єдине, що рухалося,
коли я був там, був вітер  деякі
люди думають, що для мене це самотнє місце,
воно прекрасне, і це дало мені можливість
глибоко задуматися. Я працюю лікарем
у великому місті, і я завжди дуже зайнятий,
тому мир і тиша під час поїздки були
однією з головних причин  що я вирішив
поїхати до Патагонії, але там також
є чим зайнятися,
я катався на конях і гірських велосипедах
, а також гуляв годинами
лугами або памперсами, коли я робив,
що я бачив цих незвичайних кондорів, які
кружляли в повітрі наді мною  також були
вівці скрізь. Патагонія добре
відома своїми вівцями, а
пастухів там називають гаухарами, також є
багато ранчо, які виникли
в естанції. Зараз все
більше людей приїжджає  до Патагонії
та естанції стають туристичними
визначними пам'ятками, на щастя, я подружився
з Аною, місцевою вчителькою, яка
запросила мене до традиційної естанції своєї сім'ї
в чудовій долині за кілька
сотень кілометрів від міста
Ячмен-Ой під час мого візиту я також
спробував місцеву їжу  і це було справді
смачно на головну їжу дня,
ми б смажили баранину
або асадо, як вони це називають, зі спеціальним
соусом під назвою чімічуррі, зелений салат,
свіжий хліб і газована джерельна вода
. Дядько Анни — гаучо, і він розповів нам
про старі часи  коли він був
зовсім один на ранчо і днями не бачив
іншу людину,
ви знаєте, що ранчо неймовірно
великі, він описав, що йому доводилося проходити 20
кілометрів між двома вівцями в
звичайний день під час мого походу, я також
досліджував гори  Я пішов до
втраченого класу швидкої допомоги, оскільки в національному парку ставало все
холодніше й холодніше, коли я йшов
горами з невеликою групою
німецьких туристів, але було добре  Варто того,
мабуть, найкраще у всій
подорожі було коли раптом я побачив
рожевих фламінго біля блискучого озера,
це було майже захід сонця, було
захоплююче бути частиною природи так, що ми
збиралися плисти всіма озерами  теж,
але, на жаль, щось пішло не так,
і це було скасовано.
Я також чув багато історій про
Pumas, але, на жаль, я
не бачив жодної, але через чотири-п’ять
років, коли мої діти стануть достатньо дорослими, щоб
піти зі мною,
я обов’язково повинен повернутися до Південної
Америки  і хто знає, що я побачу, що
Сем зробив, давайте перевіримо відповіді, тож
питання номер 1, що, на вашу думку,
можуть побачити і зробити туристи, які відвідують Патагонію,
а другий – про
тварин, подивіться на фотографії, кажуть,
що варто зробити  давайте назвемо їх
разом, перший - це катання на конях,
хороша робота, наступний - катання на гірських велосипедах,
отримайте номер 3 відстеження,
повторіть цей червоний набір для відстеження, а
останній гуляйте по
лугах  зрозуміло, що щодо тварин,
вони безперечно вівці зверніть увагу
тут sheep іменник в англійській мові в одній
і множині без змін, оскільки вівці та вівці
правильно,
але тепер ви будете слухати один і той самий
запис і одночасно, і завдання
вірне  /false, як у Z, теж немає завдання, спочатку
давайте подумаємо, які етапи ми
повинні охопити, підготуючись до прослуховування,
тож коли ви виконуєте завдання true/false,
згадайте перший крок, прочитайте твердження та
передбачте зміст, що робити далі
Обведіть ключові слова в кожному  зверніть
увагу на цю послідовність речень,
що дає вам, коли вам вдається
вловити інформацію про друге
та четверте твердження, але все ще не
знаєте, як відповісти на
твердження номер три, будьте дуже обережні,
оскільки ця частина інформації знаходиться
між тими, які ви чули  про номер
два та номер чотири правильно, і ще
одна ідея, читаючи перефразування висловлювань,
подумайте про можливі
синоніми, протилежні правильно, тому що
навряд чи можна почути ті самі слова
будьте трохи іншими, подивіться на ці
твердження, ось вісім із них у Z
знаю, що є лише п’ять що -
перший правий прочитайте ці твердження, тому
твердження номер один
Джейн описує відстеження як приємні
прогулянки, які можуть бути значущими словами
тут Приємні прогулянки
правильно  означає, що ми повинні почути, чи
подобається Джейн приємним, чи подобається їй цей досвід чи ні,
інший Джейн вважає це місце самотнім,
давайте разом подумаємо про емоції, які
ви відчуваєте, коли ви чуєте слово самотня
позитивне чи негативне самотнє, як у
пісні lonely I'm  так самотньо, насправді
не дуже позитивно, це означає, що ми повинні звернути
увагу на те, що і як Джейн описує
це місце, чи робить воно щасливим чи
не дуже щасливим для наступного.
Патагонія відома своїми вівцями, які називаються
культурами, яку інформацію
ми повинні ловити тварин  Патагонія
відома і як її називають такою
назвою чи, можливо, іншою, решту виконайте
самостійно, аналізуйте речення, намагайтеся
передбачити можливість  промовте слова та зосередьтеся на
значущих словах десять секунд, щоб зробити це,
так що готові до свистка давайте зробимо це
я щойно повернувся з мандрівної
відпустки в Південній Америці, це був мій
перший похід, я вважаю, що найкраще це можна
описати як прогулянку для насолоди
під час  моє перебування в Південній Америці я пішов
на патагонську сходинку, це величезне
майже порожнє місце, єдине, що рухалося,
поки я був там, був вітер, деякі
люди думають, що це самотнє місце для мене,
воно прекрасне, і це дало мені можливість
глибоко задуматися.  працюю лікарем
у великому місті, і я завжди дуже зайнятий,
тому тиша і спокій під час поїздки були
однією з головних причин, чому я вирішив
поїхати в Патагонію, але там також
є чим зайнятися,
я покатався на конях і в горах  їздив на велосипеді
, а також гуляв годинами
лугами чи памперсами, коли я робив
це, я бачив цих незвичайних кондорів, які
кружляли в повітрі наді мною, також були
вівці всюди, де Патагонія добре
відома своїми вівцями та  d
пастухів там називають go cheese, є
також багато ранчо, які називаються
estancia. Зараз
до Патагонії приїжджає все більше людей,
а естанції стають туристичними
визначними пам'ятками, на щастя, я подружився
з Аною, вчителькою місцевої школи, яка
запросила мене до своєї родини  традиційна
естанція в прекрасній долині за кілька
сотень кілометрів від міста
ячменю Очо під час свого візиту туди я також
спробував місцеву їжу, і це було справді
смачно для основної їжі дня,
ми б смажили ягняти на грилі або асадо, як
вони це називають  спеціальний соус під назвою «
Чімічуррі», зелений салат, свіжий хліб і
газована джерельна вода. Дядько Ани —
гаучо, і він розповів нам про старі часи,
коли він був зовсім один на
ранчо і днями не бачив іншої
людини, ви знаєте, що є Раджа  настільки
неймовірно великий, що він описав, що йому довелося
пройти 20 кілометрів між двома
хлівами для овець у звичайний день під час мого
походу. Я також досліджував гори, в які
ходив  до загубленого національного парку Арас класі
ставало все холодніше й холодніше, коли я
йшов горами з
невеликою групою
німецьких туристів, але це того варте,
мабуть, найкраще у всій
подорожі було коли раптом я побачив
рожевих фламінго  внизу біля блискучого
озера був майже захід сонця, було
захоплююче бути частиною природи, що ми також
збиралися плавати по всіх озерах,
але, на жаль, щось пішло не так,
і це було скасовано,
я також чув багато історій про
Pumas, але, на жаль, я  насправді нічого не
бачив, але через чотири-п'ять
років, коли мої діти стануть достатньо дорослими, щоб
піти зі мною, я обов'язково повернуся
до Південної Америки, і хто знає, що я
побачу, і давайте перевіримо відповіді,
тож чи у вас будуть ті самі відповіді,
якщо  так добре, добре, час для бабусі,
подивіться на фрази та знайдіть
інфінітиви, тож скільки вам
вдалося знайти ще один два три,
давайте точно перевіримо три
інфінітиви перший  другий
повернувся, а третій правильно описати,
чому за першим інфінітивом він
йде після прикметника, а слово
досить старе, щоб стати хорошим.
ось чому ми використовуємо інфінітив без you get,
а третій можна описати
fool або bare bare infinitive без to,
тому що after can модальне дієслово, але воно
виглядає трохи інакше від
попередніх, перш ніж у нас було лише одне
слово infinity right come або return і
тут два слова
чому це пасивні інфінітиви чи пам'ятаєте ви
формулу так пасивний залог
бути плюс причастка минулого часу
як зробити це так минулого
дієприкметника дієслово плюс ed грати
були в третій формі take взяло було
взято добре давайте візьмемо  подивитись на
приклади пасивного інфінітиву має багато
таємниць, які потрібно відкрити, але таємниць
потрібно відкрити,
давайте переведемо це на українську Oprah
Road a stray year
Команда mahoto веде Cobras hey Dottie right
secrets to be discovered
пасивний вираз безумовно дієслово to be і причастка
минулого часу головного дієслова get
another example he come home feel
heroic and ready to be rewarded so he
was ready to be rewarded infinitive
after the prikметник
to be  винагороджується бути минулий причастий
безумовно пасивний залог отримати давайте виконаємо
це завдання сказати активні інфінітиви та
пасивні інфінітиви яка
різниця подивіться на питання, чи хотіли б ви
надати чи отримати присутність,
знайдіть тут активний та пасивний інфінітив
, який слід дати, щоб бути  дано так
дарувати це активно і бути дано це
пасивно право бути дано пасивним чому
це активне давайте подумаємо разом
я даю подарунки я б вважав за краще дарувати
подарунки тому я виконавець людина, яка
дійсно виконує дію і в
друга частина, яку мені дарують, представляє мій
актив тут або я певною мірою страждаю
від дій інших, які
дарують мені подарунок, безумовно, друга частина,
коли я даю  uk представляє його пасивний
правий, тому давайте розглянемо більше
прикладів я хочу допомогти їй допомогти
активному чи пасивному інфінітиву активному я
хочу допомогти йому я виконавець виконавець
гарний вона не хоче, щоб
їй допомагали вона не хоче  to be helped активний
пасивний пасивний такий неактивний to help in
passive to be helped
отримати ще один приклад ви повинні надіслати
ці листи повинні надіслати та безпристрасний
ці листи повинні бути відправлені негайно Чи
я цікавлюся Еді, де в цьому
реченні зараз мене цікавить
дія  листи слід надсилати правильно
, тому це пасивний залог отримати час
для практики скажімо, ваше завдання полягає в тому, щоб переписати
речення з активного в пасивний давайте
подивимося на приклад він хоче
одружитися з кимось одружитися активний інфінітив
давайте перетворимо це він хоче  бути одруженим
запам'ятати формулу бути та
дієприкметника минулого часу дієслова right,
щоб він хотів бути одруженим, це
п'ять речень, ваша черга, візьміть
хвилину та візьміть ручку, запишіть
числа від одного до  п'ять і напишіть ці
п'ять речень, але в пасивному
[Музика]
виконано, давайте перевіримо сандалі SAP номер один
вона хоче, щоб лікар побачив її безпристрасний,
вона хоче, щоб доктор був показаний правильно, вона
хоче, щоб доктор був показаний отримати друге
я  потрібно, щоб ти давав мені більше часу, мені
потрібно дати більше часу, скажімо, це
речення разом. Мені потрібно дати
більше часу, щоб повернути мені, в
основному, потрібно дати більше часу, але це буде шокувати, просто
скажіть це англійською: мені потрібно дати
більше  час приємний номер три Джен сподівається,
що компанія найняти його в пасивному стані Джон
сподівається, що його наймуть правильно Джон сподівається бути
найнятим сказати це Джон сподівається бути найнятим отримати
номер чотири Боб попросив когось
забрати його в аеропорту
в пасивному стані Боб попросив, щоб його взяли  вгорі
праворуч і аеропорт, тому він попросив, щоб його
забрали ваша черга,
він попросив, щоб його забрали, дістань і
останнє вони не хочуть, щоб хтось їм заважав,
тому вони не хочуть,
щоб їх турбували, вони не хочуть, щоб їх
турбували  ваша черга
вони не хочуть, щоб їх турбували добре j
тому зверніть увагу на ці фрази,
вони варто запам’ятати перше,
що є слово залишає бажати,
тому залишати бажати означає рішення,
але під час розіграшу аварії замість пустелі
ми можемо поставити все, що,
наприклад, книга залишає
бажати або  навіть залишає бажати
кращого
правильно сказати англійською: крах з вищим бюджетом.
зроблено повторив,
що потрібно зробити ще раз, що
потрібно зробити, отримати скажімо, подумати і
відповісти на ці запитання першим, які
дії слід зробити під час
ідеального відпочинку, які дії потрібно
зробити,
уявіть свої ідеальні святкові заходи
та сформулюйте фрази перша діяльність  має
бути виконано або відтворено, виконано
все, що думаєш щонайменше з трьох, і
зробіть фрази
гарними та запитання номер два, чи б ви
хотіли поїхати на відпочинок у
Патагонії  і чому ви пам'ятаєте, що ми
домовилися, що ви говорите, ви
правильно записуєте, щоб слухати це та
покращувати, отримуйте час для домашнього завдання,
ваше домашнє завдання - написати статтю
до журналу для підлітків Патагонія -
країна легендарної краси, тому не забувайте
використовуйте слова та фрази з сьогоднішнього
уроку, дзвінок дзвонить, наш урок
закінчився, тож слідкуйте за оновленнями та
до скорого побачення, до побачення
[Музика]